[Music]
in honesty page news on a stick pace
like money submitted by stinky feet hall
ad who got that I got dirty peanuts
thank you I feel like that goes hand in
hand
you have really stinky feet that are
clean so yeah some people do yeah and
they're clean
yeah do this one guy that my tattoo
artist friend was working on his legs he
had the kids of really clean feet but
then he would he sweat something like
the chi or energy or whatever it was
coming it was stark small it was a half
it was dark sighted like it was actually
combat yeah it was troll it was like the
same spirit isn't smart it was pretty
bad yeah it probably came from the same
[ __ ] demon
yeah stick around but this whole so when
he gets nervous you sweat right and then
the palms of his [ __ ] like fetuses
have sold when he would step it would it
would be footprints blueprints had a
life of their own [ __ ] bacterial
culture they're like just growing and
stinking it was so bad that after he
left my friend had a [ __ ] Lysol the
floor and spray that [ __ ] to
clean it up and it smelled like rotten
cheese dude didn't you see that a
massage that they step on you in the
lady had six yeah we go to this Korean
spa right and I'm just Korean grandma
she's massaging me and she steps on me
all over right and I'm like thank you
for the massage and I'm like what the
[ __ ] is my skin felling like baby see
he's so fat talk to her thought so
during thought you be sweat just go
through her damn [ __ ] mysterious
customers gave a waitress a thousand
dollar tip after she passed their
honesty test mom I like it it's cool but
why the [ __ ] you tested people what a
hoody did you do two thousand dollars
epic who do they think they are maybe
it's just like oh she's really cool
maybe that's what they value maybe
they're rich in the way we can help
people out but I want
I hope the honest people yes you tell me
you want to do that many collar ship I
think we know someone here's not giving
know this isn't I just feel like like
it's kind of pretentious a little bit
like homeless youth this person
passively mother you but it's your money
though it's so money to do what everyone
I know that I'll just get lucky this
mysterious is pretty ultra bit up teller
like we're going to test your honesty
and then we're going to give you this
much you just got a funny with your
shoes they thought she was good person
it's the after fact and they're like oh
that's cool I wouldn't think of doing
this and I'm going to do it that's cool
do you think if they went preemptively
to judge their waitress is wrong yeah I
think I've seen the nature I agree I
don't think there's anything wrong with
that ain't nothing wrong with both a
Brian I was wonder we go eat somewhere
and then we get a hella good right here
yeah and then you're like yeah yeah but
I'm not I'm not going in as like I'm
gonna test these people I just uh if I
had that kind of cash to throw around a
grand here and there I did it but I'm
also the guy that if my waitress sucks
or waiter I'm still tipping them yeah
thank you
name is that one lady that had the
decent man trophy that she was walking
around with and she's like one day when
I'm going to give this to a decent man
and then the decent man offered her like
a chair right at the subway because
she's pregnant or whatever it's just
like you're the first decent man in the
world here's a trophy I've been waiting
to give this to someone that's cool that
was my buddy boy your she's a stunt guy
too
do you know that guy yeah dude oh sure
that me right where we get AJK news
about him yeah yeah that's crazy
these are really cool dude like super
humbled even really nice just crying and
everything yeah
listen again Ricky Ricky be something
cuz if I saw a lady that was sweating
her ass off but I was tired that and
you're taking to see him but if I saw a
thousand dollars like falling out of her
pocket I move right along subway right
she's pregnant if she was single and hot
and I was singling haha what a jerk
hahaha that's real though for Grandma or
agama pregnant ladies need to be sitting
a lot okay we're done okay our case
should they do if they do if they do
another fact not cuz they're holding a
baby yeah because their ankles can't
[ __ ] deal with the rapid weight
change and all of a sudden you know yes
cannot hear ya the lower back to a lot
of stream so anyways this next place in
Toronto in Canada and those 90 people in
Canada except for ah I heard some Airbnb
story oh look at him no that was the
Dutch yeah it was a lawyer
yep Ontario who happy burger on oh nice
Ontario [ __ ] yep so this wait Reza name
is Melissa 22 years old she's working a
really late one night on the Saturday
night that turned into Sunday morning so
at 1:00 a.m.
these two men walked in and I guess
Bigham straight up tell her we're gonna
you know we're going to test you but
they did say something along the lines
of like they're gonna make her night and
she was like haha feels like you're
gonna make my night I don't know what
happened tonight
oh my god I think she got thousand bucks
instead it she was like what so tell me
what was she gonna do those bananas what
was she gonna do it too
[Laughter]
[Music]
I just imagined a Bellagio water stop
the body is super chunky teashop starts
spinning one of the men is 27 years old
described as having dark brown hair a
scruffy beard and blue eyes
sounds like a terrorist to me she sounds
of trashes the second dude he was 40
years old had a youthful appearance
tanned skin and had dirty blond hair
what kind of food
it's the pub some I feel like McDonald's
compared to like something are they
dropping a grand
there's no waitress is McDonald's little
friend olive in Toronto it's not the
employee not wait chester cheshire yeah
different artists different art forms
yeah so then I started they were just
waiting for her to clean up cuz she was
getting ready to go home she cleaned up
all her tables and they kept asking like
hey yo can you sit with us
we like the creepy right [ __ ] creepy
Jews right now am I making sense now
yeah yeah bar primary so what I was
thinking is they say like like things as
she's working
yeah me too I'm with you with that this
is weird like sit down we're gonna
analyze [ __ ] no pretension it's not
like I'm better than you I'm going to
see if your life at my level
I agree the thing that they were really
friendly and funny and jewelry she
agreed to sit down with them cuz of the
[ __ ] bananas yeah she wanted to be
mmm I guarantee she want a double dicks
that night okay she didn't get it she
just got money instead I would hate to
bid that position how much I worked so
hard I just need a little dick tonight I
get two dicks
I'm ready to fight you for the price of
one I mysteriously clean I'm getting
ready whoo humming the song yeah she's
like
i'ma get to [ __ ] hot dogs in my one
bundle is like fire does come off a
little presented so they're saying that
they told her that the way that she
handles the bills would determine her
outcome and then they appreciate honesty
more than anything that's available
they're basically saying we're testing
you but what's a handle of boo I don't
know maybe this is awesome like if she
says like they drink three sodas she
didn't or like the way she drops the
bill like I don't know what they meant
by that or she gonna do it Chinese now
Chinese style
[Laughter]
Korean Japanese check this out not even
exaggerating so then they asked her like
would you mind answering some questions
and she was like yeah sure whatever
she's like I've been at really weird
questions being a server server so she
didn't really mind was he like please
keep them calm she can't even [ __ ]
close out because she still has this
table open so of course she's like [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] do you want
so then they asked her about her
ambitions where she wanted to travel
what you would do if she could do
anything and she told them that she
would love to just have her career be in
music because she loved music so much
and that's her passion she would like to
turn that into a career
who doesn't love music I love music I
turn that [ __ ] off I absolutely hate all
music so then they even threw in a
random question here and there they
asked her what her favorite Bruce
Springsteen song was was the artist head
singing that song go to Chile and
Robitaille in turn put 1000 somewhere in
there one oh I don't know
that's better she says it's her favorite
musician about boutiques in some
respects he's never there for so what's
the favorite song I couldn't think of
the [ __ ] name before you said that to
me forget it he'll joke sorry as I ended
up answering that she didn't know any
she's just being on it and so they were
like all right good good you did good on
that question
wait that's all yeah what was she gonna
say Mexican I am yeah what's your
favorite song from Queen don't know it
she's so honest
why aren't you also honest about her
passion and what she would do and like
she's nothing to be [ __ ] lying about
though yeah that's why I thought it
would be like a subliminal test yeah I
could go to King Taco right now and be
like y'all Jose what did you really
wanna hahahaha
what did you you don't want to [ __ ] a
working taco right he goes actually like
it or it could be like I wanted to work
at the rodeo you know like one of those
you know I think anybody would answer
that if a stranger asked you you're a
waiter and they said what do you really
want to be they know waiter wants me
away there I guess or if you ask Jose
like name me a Bruce Springsteen song I
was gonna say I don't know haha
The Odyssey in his Mane is so honest
didn't even try to [ __ ] entertain so
then they were happy with her answers
and so when they were filling out the
bill or the check it was just a $31
check but then they added an additional
$1,000 for her tip and then she saw it
she immediately started crying and she
was like this is a mistake did you
really mean to write that like where are
the cameras like she just couldn't
believe it she was so shocked
that's all so it's not real bit rich you
a liar and then the two guys were saying
that so then these two men were saying
that occasionally they like to Zone in
on servers from time to time and then to
see where their ambitions lines to be
like how honest they really are with the
questions that they provide and so
they'll just give them like a surprise
bonus tip I don't like this why she's
are your holiday basically I that's
really Oh like this is mental rape it is
it's like war fort monkey targeting this
[ __ ] right here I'm going to ask them
what their dreams are your what if her
dream with some else yeah I'm using like
are they going to say on what you want
it you actually wanted to be a waiter
yeah I want to be a lawyer you didn't
pass yeah so this is Melissa was her tip
for the receipt of precision that's why
she's a pretty girl that's why she got
$1,000 people that really needed are
like the ethnic [ __ ] illegal
immigrant server so he needs to go to
that he need go to chef needs to go to
the Chinese restaurants the Mexican
restaurants all those and help really
help someone else she doesn't look like
she was crying well this is after river
shem runs a news camera don't you know
how this is like oh my god this
so such a nice thing if you work at a
restaurant this is a everyday thing
pretty girls get [ __ ] free money they
don't even got it like really great give
great service just for existing guys
want to get attention they'll just be
like here's 200 bucks why because I'm a
regular and I want your attention
because when they come back they want
that girl to notice them you're that
kind of give me $200 yep people do that
here's another 200 just because want to
go on a days eases no but here's another
$200 that's crazy yeah dude all the time
I'll be so jealous I was like oh if I
had that kind of money I'd make it a
game like these guys not like that
though that's the thing do you know man
that's creepy though I guess it's how
you talk to them if we saw the
conversation true I do want to do that
game though but for like strictly
quality servers because I know what it's
like to be a server but I mean like you
don't have to ask some weird questions
you just let them do their job and at
the end like oh they were super dope
yeah that's all I agree because I like
that I heard it I'm like these
[ __ ] are [ __ ] yeah I don't
know probably come in there but you know
what I feel sorry for her because she
got money instead of dick what up all my
positive people I want to hear your
thoughts put it in the comments below
because if you're negative shut the hell
up and go drink some raid please but if
you're very positive leave it in the
comments below for the last video over
here
[Music]